bonjour à tous le 15 avril dernier les
sénateurs ont adopté le projet de loi
d'avenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt un texte qui
vise essentiellement à verdir
l'agriculture avec la mise en place
d'une mesure phare la création des
groupements d'intérêts économiques et
environnemental des groupes qui
rassemblent les agriculteurs aux bonnes
pratiques et c'est dernier en échange
ont des aides préférentielles mais ce
matin je vous propose de voir un point
bien particulier de ce projet de loi
l'article 4 qui aborde la question de
l'utilisation de fertilisants azotés
dans des zones déjà frappées par la
pollution sachant que ces fertilisants
azotés sont souvent à l'origine des
fameuses algues vertes tout de suite
donc retour à cette séance au Sénat le
11 avril dernier l'ordre du jour appelle
la suite de la discussion du projet de
loi adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
bavenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'article 4 article 4 j'ai
une demande de parole de Marcel denu
vous avez la parole chers
collègues madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues lorsque
j'avais demandé un temps de parole sur
cet article 4
j'avais deux observations à faire sur
cet article 4 l'une d'elles me paraî
être ule puisque sur l'aspect du bail
environnemental il me semble qu'on a
trouvé un consensus ce qui me permet
d'ajouter mes compliments à ceux qui ont
déjà été fait hier sur les qualités de
consensus du rapporteur et du président
que je veux à mon tour féliciter
i j'ai une deuxième observation sur ces
problèmes de l'azote monsieur le
ministre une observation puis une
suggestion on ne peut pas traiter de la
même manière quand on parle de l'azote
l'azote organique et l'azote minéral
c'est des problèmes techniques mais il
faut quand même le dire à ceux qui sont
chargés d'appliquer la réglementation
c'est pas la même chose ça n'a pas les
mêmes répercussions sur la qualité du
sol donc première observation ma seconde
observation j'ai fait un rapport en 2001
sur les variations climatiques à cette
époque j'avais interrogé le président de
l'Académie de médecine le professeur qui
est maintenant décédé et le professeur
Tubiana m'avait dit sa perplexité sur la
manière dont il fallait apprécier ce
chiffre de 50 mg qui n'avait aucune
justification médicale c'était il y a 14
ans ça n'a pas changé je veux vous le
redire ce n'est pas un dogme c'est un
chiffre qui est là un peu par hasard il
faut donc manier avec beaucoup de
précautions je le dis surtout pour mes
amis qui s'en servent parfois comme du
vérité médicale ce n'est pas vrai mon
deuxème point c'est de vous parler
monsieur le ministre de la manière
d'apprécier ce critère sur la pente en
matière
d'azote j'ai cultivé des terres en pente
et lorsqu'on cultivait des terre en
pente avec laacction animale on l'
bourré dans un sens perpendiculaire à la
pente parce qu'on n'avait pas la
puissance pour laborer dans le sens
montant descendant les atelages le
permettaient pas et le ruissellement
voir l'érosion qui est consécutif au
labour du sens de la pente et le
résultat de la
mécanisation lorsqu'on a un tracteur
important si on laboure en travers le
conducteur n'est pas à l'aise le
matériel travaille mal bon donc c'est le
résultat de la mécanisation or en
labourant en montant descendant on
pratique toutes les 35 ou 40 cm suivant
le matériel qu'on emploie une rigole qui
permet à l'eau de gouliné d'un boutalope
de la pente or il y a un moyen d'arrêter
cette ce phénomène qui a été créé par
les mécanisation et qui est irréversible
puisque la mécanisation continuera on va
pas revenir à l'attraction animale il y
a un moyen d'arrêter ça s'appelle la
culture sans labour dans le département
de la Somme d'où je viens nous avons
beaucoup insisté pour créer des des
cultures sangabour qui est une bonne
réponse agronomique une bonne réponse
environnement avec l'économie d'énergie
et j'ai maintenant dans le département
de la SOMUM plus de 10000 hectares
cultivés sans labour or on ne peut pas
apporter la même réponse sur les terres
en pente et sur le pourcentage de pente
aux gens qui cultivent sans labour ou à
ceux qui cultivent suivant d'autres
méthodes je souhaite donc monsieur le
ministre qu'avec vos services qui sont
capables de le faire vous avez une très
forte compétente dans tous vos services
on réfléchisse à la manière de donner un
signal pour que cette technique de
culture sans labour qui est utile et
nécessaire se développe à condition que
l'interprétation qu'on fera des textes
leur donne un signal favorable alors je
voulais vous le signaler nous sommes pas
pressés mais nous attendons ce signal
quelque part pour continuer à développer
la culture sans
labour merci chers collègues je suis
saisie de quatre amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 324
rectifier bis à Monsieur
ministre oui je vrais quand même
commencer cette matinée avec quelques
petits mots sur les grands enjeux
agronomique et je salue l'intervention
du sénateur deud par rapport à toutes
ces questions qui sont liées j'ai vu
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'amendements qui
se posent un certain nombre de questions
et je reprends deux trois sujets
importants la question de l'azote et en
particulier sur la question de la
déclaration sur les ventes d'azote
minéral il faut quand même qu'on
s'explique de manière très claire sur ce
sujet j'ai entendu hier déjà que c'était
un élément de complication suppémentaire
je rappelle quel est l'objectif et
pourquoi en Bretagne par exemple c'est
accepté par la profession
agricole toute la profession
agricole à l'échelle de la Chambre
d'Agriculture régionale et par les
syndicats agricoles j'ai bien dit les
syndicats
quel est l'objectif de cette déclaration
d'azote minéral qui ne concerne pas les
agriculteurs mais les distributeurs
d'azote et qui se met en place à titre
expérimental après décision au niveau de
la
région la Bretagne étant la première
région qui va expérimenter cette
mesure je rappelle il s'agit de
substituer
à l'azote minéral qui est acheté
aujourd'hui et épendu sur les terres en
Bretagne l'excédent d'azote organique
qui est lié à la à l'élevage
breton principe
simple je vous rappelle en plus que
l'azote c'est du
gaz et on
importe ce gaz et donc cet azote alors
qu'on a de l'excédent d'azote organique
qui souvent au lieu d'aller fertiliser
les terres et les plantes va dans les
rivières et ensuite faire ce qu'on sait
c'est-à-dire des algues vertes donc le
principe c'est de se mettre en ordre de
bataille pour substituer à l'azote
minéral acheté et importé qui coûte cher
l'azote organique en excédent mais pour
arriver à faire ça il faut qu'on soit
capable de savoir combien il y avait
d'azote minéral de vendu les
agriculteurs ça ne change rien pour eux
c'est les distributeurs et les vendeurs
d'azote qui qui devront déclarer les
quantités qu'ils ont vendu dans une
année de référence qui sera l'année 2000
2014 et puis après on calculera la
substitution la baisse de l'azote
minéral et c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'une déclaration donc faut pas se
tromper dans ce
débat je le dis vraiment à tous les
sénateurs qui ont que j'ai entendu hier
ou même dans les amendements que j'ai vu
laisse penser que cette déclaration ça
serait encore une norme supplémentaire
non c'est un objectif extrême clair qui
va permettre d'utiliser l'azote
organique qui
est produit ici plutôt que d'importer de
l'azote minéral voilà le sujet de la
même manière sur la question de la
méthanisation qu'est-ce que c'est que la
méthanisation il y a un rapport de l'adè
je le dis quand même ici ce matin un
rapport de l'adè qui indique que si on
valorisait l'ensemble du méthane lié à
la production de matière organique
aujourd'hui en France on arriverait on
arriverait à produire en méthane dans le
réseau près de 40 % de ce qu'on consomme
aujourd'hui en
gaz et je le répète gaz impimporté et
vous savez de quelle région le sud ou
quelquefois de l'Est avec les sujets
géopolitiques géostratégiques qui vont
avec là on a un potentiel de gaz
j'allais dire naturel je fais ça entre
guillemets qui est là et on ne le
valorise pas dans le système de l'azote
total avec derrière la méthanisation
c'est le fameux plan MMA qui est en
cours de mise en œuvre c'est ça
l'objectif aussi c'est de faire en sorte
que ce qui est un déchet aujourd'hui
devienne une
ressource et l'agriculture a une
potentialité il s'agit pas de substituer
la production de gaz le méthane à une
production agricole il s'agit de faire
en sorte que la production agricole qui
génère de la matière organique puisse
valoriser cette matière organique au
travers du méthane pour faire du gaz
c'est ça l'objectif aussi on est
parfaitement dans l'idée d'économie
circulaire et donc on a des
simplifications à faire parce que ça ça
m'a été posé comme question il y a plein
de projets mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
toujours des difficultés simplifier les
procédures c'est engagé c'est la
procédure unique de déclaration que ça
soit l'éolien que ça soit le solaire que
ça soit le méthan on a une seule
déclaration à faire et pas trois
établissement classés tout un tas de
problèmes euh à gérer s'est engagé à
titre expérimental pour les 3 années qui
viennent on va accélérer ce processus il
y a aussi des questions sur les prix de
rachat hein et la dégressivité par
exemple lorsqu'on fait des systèmes
collectifs qui finissent par remettre en
cause on avait le débat hier les
systèmes collectifs au détriment des
systèmes individuels et qui surtout
pourrait si on ne peut pas développer de
manière plus structurante les systèmes
collectifs faire que un certain nombre
d'exploitation de taille moyenne n'est
pas accès à la méthanisation parce
qu'ils onent pas les capacités de
financer des projets collectifs au
travers de la dégr agivité en
particulier du prix de rachat donc on a
plein de sujets sur lesquels il faut
qu'on continue de travailler sur les
déclarations sur les IPE aussi mais ayez
conscience dans l'esprit de cette loi
qu'on est dans un processus qui va dans
le sens
d'enclencher une capacité à
l'agriculture de pouvoir valoriser ce
qui a été considéré comme des déchets
aujourd'hui comme des ressources ce qui
sur la question de l'azote consiste à
dire tout simplement que plutôt que
d'importer de l'azote minéral et du gaz
et bien utilisons mieux et de manière
plus rationnelle l'azote organique qui
est disponible lorsqu'il est en excédent
c'est ça aussi le principe et puis sur
les grandes questions agronomiques qui
ont été évoquées par Monsieur Deneu
c'est d'accompagner tout ça avec des
modèles agronomiques qui permettent
justement de mieux absorber l'azote de
mieux le garder de mieux le séquestrer
dans les sols et de mieux le délivrer
ensuite pour les plantes plutôt que de
l'utiliser en épendage qui souvent finit
dans les rivières ou ailleurs c'est ça
l'objectif voilà je voulais rappeler au
moment où on va discuter beaucoup
d'amendements ne nous trompons pas il y
a pas plus de normes il y a simplement
un changement de modèle et
d'approche merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur revet c'est sur article c'est
sur l'article c'est une parole sur
l'article alors je vous en prie allez-y
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues de mots
parce que il y a encore je sais plus
combien près de 700 amendements et on
est vendredi et Monsieur le Ministre
très bien ce que vous veneez de dire on
partage tout à fait mais on fait comment
je veux dire par là il faut le dire ici
on le partage et pour celles et ceux qui
sur le terrain le pratique on est un
certain nombre de d'agriculteurs ou
d'anciens agriculteurs ici on partage le
principe monsieur le ministre mais après
qu'est-ce que l'on fait je vous rappelle
que la France était le principal
producteur agricole en matière de viande
de lait et autres euh de l'Europe il y a
encore 10 15 ou 20 ans et aujourd'hui
les Allemands ont pris nous ont remplacé
et alors que nous leur vendions du lait
nous leur vendions de la viande de porc
et autres aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui
nous le vendent pourquoi pourquoi
Monsieur le Ministre si vous voulez bien
m'écouter 30 secondes tout simplement
parce que la politique agricole en
Allemagne a été complètement changé et à
l'image j'entends encore mon collègue AR
Baili dire s'agissant des agneaux qui
venant de Nouvelle-Zélande que la valeur
ajoutée la la valeur là-bas c'était la
laine et non pas la viande et que nous
vendait la viande d'agneaux à à bas prix
et donc concurrençait nos agneaux et
bien là c'est la même chose la
production de méthane en Allemagne a
fait en sorte que les coûts de
production de du lait et de la viande en
Allemagne ont diminué fortement et qu'il
nous concurrence alors chiche je crois
que les agriculteurs sont prêts je suis
pas breton je suis normand mais ils sont
prêts à faire mais par-delà le discours
parce que c'est bien de de dire le
discours monsieur le ministre il y a des
amis qui vont le reprendre qui sont dans
cette hémicycle ou autre pour encore
fusiller les agriculteurs mais alors
mettons au point dans un accord entre
les élus les responsables et et les
professionnels euh un dispositif qui
fasse que on puisse permettre à nos
agriculteurs de réaliser ce que vous
faites mais il va falloir les aider
comme les Allemands les les le
l'Allemagne a aidé ses
producteurs merci chers collègues
l'amendement 324 rectifié bis monsieur
César vous le
présentez madame la Présidente j'ai bien
entendu le plaidoyer du ministre par
rapport donc à ces zones il faut lui
rendre hommage parce que c'est ça
concerne uniquement les zones
vulnérables c'est ce qui est écrit dans
le texte hein et ça ça me paraît
important de le souligner mais après il
est dit il est dit l'autorité administ
pe imposer aux personnes qui détiennent
à titre professionnel des matières
fertilisantes àjter à cette zone y
compris aux transporteurs de ces matière
une déclaration annuelle relative aux
quantités d'azote qu'ils ont traité reçu
livré cédé à tire gratuit ou onéreux
dans la zone où qu'ils ont céd à toute
personne qui expédie ou livre dans cette
zone les matières fertilisantes azotées
donc aujourd'hui notre amendement 324 a
pour objectif donc de supprimer les
alinéas de 1 à 6 et moins de contraintte
Monsieur le Ministre moins de normes
moins de et nous sommes à l'époque où on
veut simplifier l'administration de la
France et on enom complexifie encore
plus donc nous sommes opposés à à cette
solution qui n'est pas bonne dans
l'article
4 le 379 rectifié le 518 rectifié sont
identiques monsieur Collin avez-vous
quelque chose à rajouter ou je peux
considérer qu'il est défendu il est
défendu je vous remercie monsieur le
monsieur
non ne perdons pas de temps c'est le
c'est le c'est le même amendement
transposons-nous dans la réalité des
pratiques nous avons l'absolu garanti
qu'en zone vulnérable cet amendement ne
touche ce texte ne touche que les zones
vulnérables ok il faut y faire des
efforts on a la garantie que les
agriculteurs ont
l'obligation de déclarer la totalité de
leurs apports azotés qu'il soi chimique
ou qu'il soit d'autres origines animales
notamment je ne sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte de la complexité inutile
que l'on rajoute aux pratiques normales
on est dans une période mon recherche de
la simplification administrative nous
avons là un tout petit endroit hein où
il serait facile de ne pas alourdir de
ne pas compliquer imaginons un instant
également dans ces zones dites fragiles
la loi l'autorisant toutes les
tentatives qu'il y aura de la faire
appliquer alors moi je suis très étonné
que l'on complique à souet un problème
qui est
réglé merci monsieur laasser le 240
rectifi bis monsieur denu vous pouvez le
défendre il est
défendu non mais monsieur deu peut le
défendre madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre il s'agit d'ajouter à
l'alinéa 5 après les mots ces matières
les mots et ou au prestatair de
servicees dépendag en effet ces services
dépendages jouent un rôle non
négligeable et joueront de plus en plus
dans la mesure où il s'agit
d'entreprises spécialisées par
lesquelles nous avons de plus en plus de
besoins pour des travaux spécialisé je
vous remercie chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur l'avis de la commission
sur les trois amendements identiques
donc un avis et sur le 240 rectifie
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bonjour
nous démarrons la la journée par un
sujet très
important d'abord dans le dans la loi il
est bien indiqué mais ça a été dit par
Monsieur César et par Monsieur lasser
c'est dans les zones vulnérables donc
déjà enlevant tous les faux débats tout
le reste zones vulnérables mais s'il y a
ça pour les zones
vulnérables c'est bien que on part de
quelque chose et c'est bien qu'il a eu
une une façon d'appréhender cette
agriculture et les pendages d'azote
depuis 30 ans qui a fait que nous avons
pollué les sols ça c'est une réalité et
aujourd'hui personne ne sait quell
conséquen cela peut avoir sur la santé
et sur l'environnement mais surtout sur
la santé de l'homme aucune étude
sérieuse n'a été faite sur les polluants
en faible dose en mélange et dans la
durée personne personne ni ceux qui sont
pour ni ceux qui sont contre c'est la
raison pour laquelle je fait ma première
pub de la journée dans la
Drome va être
construit un pôle de recherche en
toxicologie environnementale et en
écotoxicologie unique unique en Europe
validé par l'État validé par toutes les
universités validé par les pôles de
recherch mondiaux pour savoir si oui ou
non nous en parlions hier avec Madame
Blandin le principe de précaution soit
d'un côté ne sarent pas pousser au bout
à de l'obscurantisme soit de l'autre
côté on dit que ça ne sert à rien et
bien il faut objectiver le principe de
précaution mais il y a une chose dont on
est sûr c'est que les pendages qu'il y a
eu pendant toutes ces années toute
l'azote qui a été dans les sols a fait
très mal et je dirais à Monsieur revet
que nous sommes tous sur le terrain moi
je ne suis pas agriculteur mais je
prétends connaître un peu l'agriculture
dans mon territoire et il y a aussi des
zones des zones des des pendages et si
la PO la politique agricole allemande a
changé ben c'est bien pour ça que le
ministre aujourd'hui avec cette loi
d'avenir veut la changer parce qu'on se
compare toujours à l'Allemagne mais
enfin si on a quelques difficultés
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être bien sans
aucun esprit polémique que la politique
agricole française menée depuis ces
dernières années n'a pas forcément très
bien marché parce que si elle avait bien
marché on n'aurait pas entendu depuis 3
jours problème de revenus problème de
dépris et cetera et tout ce qu'on voit
dans cette loi donc la loi qui est mis
en place par le par le ministre le fol
c'est justement pour essayer de régler
un ce nombre de problème et puis après
Stéphane Lefol de la même couleur
politique ou d'une alternance il y aura
sûrement un autre ministre de
l'Agriculture qui fera une autre qui
fera une autre loi mais enfin nous
l'évoquions dans la discussion générale
la LMAP que nous avons débattu en 2009
c'est pas loin 2009 elle avait des
points très positifs mais sur tous ces
sujets elle n'a rien amené et si nous
sommes obligés d'en parler aujourd'hui
c'est qu'elle n'a rien amené donc sur
ces sujets il faut bien il faut bien il
faut bien avancer et puis vous parliez
des aides pour les agriculteurs je pense
quand même que avec la PAC avec la
politique menée par le chef de l'État et
le le ministre nous sommes arrivés quand
même dans cette dans cette direction à
sauver ce dont on pensait qu'il n'était
pas sauvable alors c'est sûrement pas
assez pour les uns c'est bien pour les
autres on n'est là pas là pour
polémiquer mais je parlais d'un constat
alors ensuite sur la suppression de
déclaration de obligatoire de flux
d'azote moi je pense Monsieur Daniel
Dubois hier a fait voter un amendement
sur les normes sur la il y a un moment
où il y en a marre il y en a marre des
normes faut pas en rajouter sans cesse
sans cesse sans cesse mais enfin mais
enfin il y a norme énorme quand même et
ça ce qui est mis dans cette dans cette
dans cette loi sur le sur la déclaration
obligatoire c'est bien quand même pour
essayer de faire en sorte que ça les
choses ne s'empirent pas et c'est pas un
procès d'intention on sait très bien que
tout le monde tout le monde essaie de
faire le mieux possible pour les
agriculteurs vous avez raison monsieur
lasser monsieur César ils font déjà
leurs déclarations c'est pas la peine
d'en rajouter c'est pour ça que ce qui
est dit dans la loi on n'en rajoute pas
ils font déjà leur leur déclaration donc
il y a pas de sujet là-dessus et on ne
complique pas pour les pour les
agriculteurs ce qui semble vous poser
problème c'est sur les
transporteurs voilà et nous en avons
beaucoup parlé en commission et nous en
parlons encore en apparté avec le
président Raoul et on se disait mais
après tout si nous étions des gens
concrets pragmatiques comme vous dites
si on enlevait du texte transporteur et
distributeur est-ce que ça serait pas
mieux ben non je suis désolé de vous
dire que ça ne serait pas mieux parce
que si on avait pu le faire vous
connaissezel Raoul il l'aurait proposé
et nous l'aurions fait pourquoi c'est
pas possible pourquoi c'est pas possible
parce que si on enlève mais je sais
qu'on est pas d'accord monsieur ça mais
si on enlève les transporteurs non mais
non mais c'est pas un contrôle encore si
on enlève je vais vous dire pour pour
quoi si on enlève les transporteurs
alors là vous pourrez dire qu'il y a la
discrimination positive et négative ça
voudrait dire que seuls les agriculteurs
sont obligés de faire une déclaration
d'azote et les transporteurs ne seraient
pas obligés et quand une quand un ga
quand une structure va chercher de
l'azote à tel endroit et l'amène dans sa
structure c'est quand même bien normal
que le transporteur là c'est pas une
norme pour les agriculteurs c'est pour
que les transporteurs le déclarent alors
après soit on se dit c'est bien pour la
santé c'est bien pour l'environnement
c'est bien pour faire pour contrôler
cela parce que le mot contrôle il a pas
forcément des des connotations toujours
négatives on veut améliorer les choses
soit on se dit on veut pas les contrôles
pour les transporteurs les distributeurs
ça veut dire peut-être je dis pas pour
vous hein surtout pas pour vous aucun
procè d'intention mais ça veut dire
peut-être que finalement on préfère que
rien ne soit contrôlé sur le sujet et
puis que l'on fasse comme avant et je
pense vraiment que si nous faisions
comme avant alors nous ne serions pas
responsable vis-à-vis du Grenel dans
l'environnement et vis-à-vis de la santé
de nos petits-enfants c'est la raison
pour laquelle je crois vraiment que dans
les zones vulnérabl uniquement
vulnérable déclaration annuelle pour les
agriculteurs très bien rajouter les
transporteurs et les distributeurs c'est
pas un contrôle supplémentaire ça permet
tout simplement une vérification de la
situation de l'azote dans ces zones
vulnérable et voir si les choses se
passent plutôt bien je pense franchement
que il faut pas voir réglementation et
norme toujours de façon négative vous
savez ce que j'en pense il faut les
diminuer mais sur le sujet je crois
qu'il en va de la santé de l'homme et il
en va de la santé des sols et de
l'environnement c'est pas un contrôle
supplémentaire c'est une vérification
objective de la situation monsieur le
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai pas entendu votre
avis alors vous aurez compris que je
mettais un avis défavorable à la
suppression le 240 rectifié bis
également monsieur le rapport
orteur attendez là j'ai mal démarré je
me suis laissé qu'est-ce que vous dites
madame la
Présidente le le 240 rectifi B je mets
un avis favorable à l'amendement de
Monsieur ad j'ai bien fait de vous le
demander monsieur le
ministre sur cette question de l'azote
et par rapport aux interrogations qui
sont les votes d'abord le rapport entre
la France et l'Allemagne en terme de
production agricole reste le suivant la
France c'est 19% de la production
agricole européenne quand l'Allemagne
c'est autour de 11
% ils ont progressé mais il y a quand
même encore une marge et nous il faut
qu'on soit capable de reprendre en
tenant compte de l'environnement une
marche qui nous permett de soutenir et
de développer notre production donc on
est tous d'accord làdessus sur la
question de
l'azote dans une zone d'excédent d'azote
structurel la vraie question qui est
posée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout est calculé sur la
matière organique azotée les
agriculteurs sont obligés de tout
déclarer et ils sont bloqués et
plafonnés c'est le cas en Bretagne ou
dans d'autres
endroits si on veut justement desserrer
un peu les taux qui fait que tout est
bloqué aujourd'hui et que la production
porcine je prends celle-là en Bretagne a
été diminué depuis 10 ans de près de 5 à
7 % le nombre de cochons à baisser avec
les conséquences que l'on sait en terme
industriel si j'ai donc un excédent
d'azote
organique et tout le système et c'est
logique par rapport à la Commission
Européenne j'ai de l'excédent d'azote
organique donc j'ai dois avoir des plans
dépendage et cet azote organique doit
être calculé de telle manière qu'il
s'adapte au plan dépendage quel est le
problème c'est qu'en Bretagne là o on a
des zones d'excédent d'azote organique
on
achète de l'azote minéral
oui mais donc par rapport à l'Europe
pour sortir justement de
cette ce côté de cette quadrature du
cercle je ne peux pas avoir plus d'azote
organique mais en même temps je continue
à acheter de l'azote minéral qu'est-ce
qu'on
fait c'est complètement schizophrène
qu'est-ce qu'on dessert comme ÉAU ben on
dit là où on a d'azote organique en
excédent on pourra le substituer à
l'azote minéral qui vient aujourd'hui
dans ces zones d'excédent et ça
permettra de libérer justement les
contraintes qui
existent mais pour faire ça vis-à-vis de
l'Europe faut quand même qu'on
s'explique peut pas faire n'importe quoi
donc on est obligé d'avoir une
déclaration sur l'azote minéral pour
voir la substitution entre l'excédent
d'azote organique et la baisse de
l'azote minéral c'est pour ça qu'on fait
ces déclarations elles sont faites par
les coopératives et les dist
distributeur d'azote ça ne concerne pas
les agriculteurs mais vous êtes d'accord
avec moi qu'en Bretagne il y a des
coopératives et des distributeurs
d'azote qui sont locaux mais qu'on peut
tout à fait faire venir de l'azote
minéral d'ailleurs et là on est obligé
de demander une déclaration sur les
transporteurs c'est pour
ça mais ça va exactement dans le sens
que vous voulez comment desserrer des
étaau comment faire en sorte qu'en
tenant compte des contraintes
environnementales on arrive à desserrer
les étau c'est ça l'enjeu de ces
déclarations c'est pas autre chose donc
faut surtout pas se tromper sur
l'objectif je comprends bien entendu
monsieur César mais il faut que vous
compreniez que ce qu'on est en train de
faire avec l'azote total là cette
question là c'est un changement complet
d'approche qui est pas là pour justement
brider mais qui est là pour être plus
rationnel dans l'utilisation de l'azote
organique diminuer l'utilisation de
l'azote minéral et permettre de
décoincer des situations dans lesquelles
depuis des années tout tu es bloqué
c'est ça l'enjeu bon il y a pas d'autrre
enjeu c'est pour ça que je suis sur la
ligne du rapporteur pour dire que sur
cet amendement là c'est défavorable
parce que ça nous empêcherait de faire
ce qu'on veut
faire me manque un avis du gouvernement
sur le 240 ractifier bis c'est favorable
sagesse sagesse je vous remercie très
bien ah Monsieur le présid monsieur le
rpportteur simplement l'amendement de
Monsieur de Monsieur ADNA là que j'ai
accepté il y a simplement une petite
rectification à faire il y a et ou au
prestataire et à remplacer par et au
prestataire mais ça pose pas de ça pose
pas de sujet je crois ah mais monsieur
c'est vous qui le défendiez monsieur
denu je suis je suis désolé comme je
voyais pas monsieur
ad vous acceptez chers collègues
monsieur le ministre le rapporteur moi
j'accepte la rectification elle est
convenable mais d'abord je voudrais
remercier le rapporteur d'avoir compris
l'esprit mais je voudrais profiter de
mon temps de parole monsieur le ministre
pour revenir de mot mot sur la
métanisation depuis 3 ans je participe
je ne sais pas à quel titre comme
parlementaire au bureau d'abord puis
maintenant à l'office par à l'Office
Franco-Allemand des énergies
renouvelables le 14 février dernier nous
avons fait une journée entière à Paris
sur la métanisation or le gouvernement
français é TER représenté mais pas par
votre ministère or c'est vous qui me
paraissez détenir la vérité dans C cette
affaire sur le plan technique il y a un
problème d'organisation gouvernementale
que je vous demande de voir un mot pour
vous montrerù nous en somme en
méthanisation on a fait le point il y a
un mois il y a aujourd'hui 7240
méthanisurs qui fonctionnent en
Allemagne en France il n'y en a pas 30
qui crachent du gaz réellement et
l'autoroute à 1 et l'autoroute à 16 dans
ma région de Picardie sont le grand
chemin de transfert qui emmène tous nos
déchets ménagers vers la Belgique si
bien que du côté équilibre de la
fermentation de nos méthaniseurs nous
donnons au belges les capacités
techniques de métanisé et nous allons
nous en priver si nous n'allons pas
assez vite il faut être très observateur
de ces problèmes et faire
vite merci chers collègues la parole est
à Madame primat madame prima c'est fini
monsieur
Dubois madame la Présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre moi je ne mets pas du tout en
doute votre sincérité par rapport à ce
qui vient d'être
dit par rapport au à la possibilité qui
serait offerte à travers ces contrôle
finalement de rendre un service aux
agriculteurs et et au territoire mais
permettez-moi de douter de
l'administration permettez-moi d'en
douter parce que quand on lit
l'alinéa ça ouvre tellement de portes
aux excessifs contrôles qui sont menés
je dirais dans ces domaines je suis
malheureusement malheureusement monsieur
le ministre persuadé je dis bien
persuadé que nos agriculteurs
souffriront de nouveaux contrôles
tatillons sur ces sujets et je voudrais
vous donner un exemple précis
effectivement face à l'Europe
sur ces zones euh donc nous avons sur
ces zones vulnérables des difficultés et
que nous
sommes j' dire prêt à payer enfin prêt
peut-être pas mais en tous les cas nous
sommes soumis à des amendes par rapport
à cela il y a donc eu des extensions de
zones vulnérables récemment et dans le
département d'où je viens le département
de la Somme il y a eu un accord entre
les agriculteur monsieur le ministre
votre administration l'administration du
pays en génér pour que effectivement il
y ait un suivi sur des zones considérées
comme sensibles afin que
effectivement l'effort mené par les
agriculteurs puisse être mesuré cela a
été fait cela a été mesuré et
effectivement sur une certaine zone chez
nous au bord de l'ti il était démontré
que les agriculteurs avaient fait des
efforts et que effectivement la présence
d'azote avait diminué en tous les cas
était stabilisé dans le cadre des
extensions monsieur le ministre des
zones vulnérables alors que ce
territoire avait fait des efforts alors
que nous avions toute l'administration
départementale en soutien de nos
agriculteurs le préfet coordonnateur a
pris la décision d'étendre la zone
vulnérable à cette zone où des efforts
avaient été faits par les des
agriculteurs ù des efforts partagés
avaient été reconnus par votre
administration il n'empêche que le
préfet coordonateur a étendu la zone
vulnérable à ce territoire où les
agriculteurs avaient fait énormément
d'efforts aujourd'hui vous êtes au
courant monsieur le ministre évidemment
puisqu'il y a des recours qui ont été
engagés naturellement jeis pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas les résultats
mais cette inquiétude elle est réelle
elle est ressentie et effectivement moi
je comprends très bien le monde agricole
face à ces obligations qui vont
permettre
neomp ne nous trompons pas sur le sujet
ça va servir à quoi bah à croiser les
contrôles
l'agriculteur fait ses déclarations vous
faites faire des déclarations au
transporteur il suffira ça veut donc
dire qu'il n'y a pas de confiance dans
le monde agricole et que vous allez
contrôler à travers je dirais des
éléments croisé pour voir si
effectivement les agriculteurs tiennent
leurs engagements mais monsieur le
ministre ils tiennent leurs engagements
sauf que quand ils les tiennent même
avec le soutien de votre administration
et bien il y a des décisions qui sont
prises et qui vont à l'encontre des
agriculteurs sur ce type de
sujet chers collègu la parole est à
Monsieur
lasser bon je crois que tout tout a été
dit il me vient à l'esprit des un cas de
figure particulier nous sommes une
justeosition de cas de figure particul
j'habite une zone frontalière une partie
importante de nos agriculteurs sont
approvisionnés livent leurs produits à
des sociétés du Pays Basque de Navar ou
d'ailleurs c'est pas énorme mais ça
devient très significatif et très
intéressant pour d'autres raisons bien
entendu de quelle façon par exemple
cette mesure va s'imposer à des sociétés
qu'on le siège à Saint-Sébastien à
Pampelune qui vont faire du commerce de
quelle façon va-t-on leur demander de
faire une déclaration annuelle je pense
qu'ils ne vont pas nous prendre au
sérieux je vous livre simplement un
petit exemple qui me vient à l'esprit
sur la difficulté l'inutilité de
l'application d'une telle mesure mais
répondez précisément à ma question s'il
vous plaît merci Monsieur monsieur
lasser monsieur Mirassou
oui madame le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues juste une
irruption dans néophy dans ce débat pas
tant que ça peut-être moi je suis
surpris très franchement et je rejoins
dans mes propos ceux qui ont été tenus
précédemment par monsieur le rapporteur
pour expliquer que nous sommes en train
de travailler sur un projet de loi qui
n'a pour seul but d'aider le monde
agricole au sens large donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a l'engagement sans faille de la
puissance publique qu'il s'agisse du
reste sur le plan national ou sur le
plan européen et ce faisant du reste le
gouvernement et le Parlement
entend assurer en quelque sorte
l'intérêt général parce que personne
n'oserait faire une différenciation
entre l'évolution du monde agricole par
rapport à ce qu'elle produit et
l'intérêt général pour autant mes chers
collègues considérons quand même que en
retour le monde agricole parce que tout
à l'heure le rapporteur l'a précisé doit
aussi intégrer dans sa réflexion qu'à
l'autre bout il y a les consommateurs il
y a les citoyens il y a les habitants du
territoire qui sont légitimement en
droit d'attendre aussi et bien de
bénéficier l'intérêt général de
l'intérêt général et ça tombe bien parce
que nous en tant que parlementaire nous
sommes à l'interface de ces deux
mondeslà qui sont trop souvent
d'ailleurs éloignés l'un de l'autre et
moi je crois que assorti à un certain
nombre de de mesures on peut quand même
imposer par rapport à ce monde qui n'est
pas directement rattaché au monde
agricole un certain nombre d'éléments
tendant au moins à le rassurer et en
tout cas parfois compte tenu du passé
j'ai failli dire du passif et bien lui
donner quelques garanties donc moi très
franchement je je suis étonné que que ce
débat parce que chaque fois qu'on
propose sur ce sujet ou sur d'autres
quelque chose qui ressem au début du
commencement d'une réglementation vous y
voyez des contraintes supplémentaires et
en quelque sorte une entrave au bon
fonctionnement du monde agricole je
pense que vous trompez le
diagnosticque monsieur Mirassou monsieur
le
ministre d'abord il il y a des choses
qui sont dites par des parlementaires
sur l'administration française moi je
veux bien que on fasse des procès sur
les fonctionnaires français l'État qui
est défendu par tout le monde a une
administration donc on on respecte une
administration ils font leur travail
après il y a des directives qui ont été
signées par des gouvernements à
l'échelle européenne c'est la fameuse
directive nitrate c'est pas de la
responsabilité des
fonctionnaires je joudrais quand même
pas qu'on finisse dans ces débats à
considérer que maintenant ça va être
administration et le fonctionnaire qui
va devenir l'ennemi de l'agriculteur le
fonctionnaire et l'administration
appliquent des lois des directives qui
ont été signés par des gouvernements et
là soyons bien clair entre nous de
droite et de gauche
sur la question de la méthanisation si
on a pris autant de retard depuis 10 15
ans quand l'Allemagne avait fait un
autre choix la seule question qu'on doit
se poser c'est comment on le rattrape ce
retard et comment on s'organise pour
éviter de faire les mêmes erreurs que
les Allemands qu'on fait du maïs pour
faire de la méthanisation et qui
commence à se dire aujourd'hui ou là là
ça va pas donc on va pas faire ces
erreurs là mais on va quand même
développer la méthanisation ça c'est le
premier point deuxè point comment
faut-il vous expliquer que j'ai déjà dit
trois fois quatre fois la
déclaration sur l'azote minéral ne
concerne pas les
agriculteurs ils sont déjà encadrés ils
sont déjà obligés de
déclarer ça concerne uniquement les
distributeur d'azote minéral pourquoi on
demande cette déclaration c'est quand
même pas possible de pas vouloir
comprendre on la demande et Monsieur ass
quand même parce que là on la demande
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes concerné
par des zones d'excédent structurel
oui dans votre département à quel
endroit oui bon sur certaines C Réal
donc on est bien sur l'azote minéral
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup de matière
organique azoté dans votre département
ah bon où ça dans les zones de montagne
dans les zones d'élevage donc comment
prenons prenons votre exemple si
laissez-moi terminer Monsieur le
Sénateur chacun a sa
parole vous avez donc dit que vous aviez
de l'azote en excédent organique bon et
vous avez dit vous-même qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'azote minéral qui étit acheté
et épendu par les
agriculteurs quel est le principe qu'on
veut mettre en place le fait qu'on
puisse substituer l'azote organique à
l'azote minéral qui est acheté
ah est-ce que c'est un mauvais principe
non c'est un bon principe et en Bretagne
en particulier si je le dis c'est parce
que les professionnels Bretons sont
d'accord quand je dis professionnels
breton c'est les agriculteurs et les
responsable professionnel quel est le
principe c'est c'est quand même pas
possible de ne pas vouloir le voir c'est
de dire pour qu'on puisse vérifier parce
que devant l'Europe on a des
responsabilités la directive nitrate
c'est pas moi qui qui l' signé on est
obligé de justifier le fait qu'on va
utiliser de l'azote organique en disant
qu'on baisse le recours à l'azote
minéral dans les zones d'excédent c'est
quand même pas dur ça concerne qui la
déclaration sur l'azote minéral pas les
agriculteurs tous ceux qui vendent de
l'azote et par définition ceux qu'ils en
vendent ceux qui en vendent de l'azote
il la transportent c'est pourquoi on
demande la déclaration au distributeurs
et au transporteurs et une fois qu'on
s'engage dans ce processus je diminue le
niveau de la pression d'excédent d'azote
organique et je remplace par l'azote
organique qui est produite par les
agriculteurs l'azote minéral qui est
importé par la France c'est pas un bon
principe ça enfin quand même et ça
n'empêche et il y a aucune contrainte
supplémentaire pour les agriculteurs
aucune qu'est-ce qui fait que vous êtes
bloqué sur cette question comment vous
pouvez m'expliquer ça donc moi je le
redis je le dis mais vraiment avec toute
la sincérité la force que j'y mets c'est
un nouveau principe donc il est
difficile peut-être à accepter à
comprendre mais il ne rajoute rien en
terme de contrainte aux agriculteurs et
il permet au contraire de débloquer des
situations où dans des zones d'excédent
on peut plus rien faire c'est bien ce
que vous voulez donc il faut aller dans
ce sens
là merci Monsieur le Ministre don je
peux plus malheureusement donner la
parole je suis je suis saisie d'un
scrutin public à moins que Monsieur le
Ministre accepte que vous ayez un droit
de réponse monsieur den puisque vous
avez été sollicité allez-y mais très
court monsieur Laer pardon
non moi je je suis prêôt accepté mais y
compris le fait que l'on comprenne
difficilement je crois plutôt qu'on ne
se comprend pas chaque fois qu'il y a
destruction d'élevage il y a destruction
d'un apport de matière organique il y a
des destructions d'élevage partout
chaque fois que dans dans les régions la
mienne notamment il est possible de
passer de l'élevage à la céréale les
gens le font pour différentes raisons il
y a donc une fluctuation dans la pro
organique qui qui est extrêmement
importante deuxième chose dites-moi au
niveau d'un stockeur et d'un
transporteur lorsqu'il fait sa
déclaration qu'il transporte que
voulez-vous qu'il en fasse si ce n'est
livré à l'agriculteur pourquoi autant de
suspicion pourquoi superposition des
contrôles on va pas refaire le débat j
jusqu'à PAC je trouve quand même que je
pense que ce dossier on l'a bien compris
on ne se comprend pas nous ne sommes pas
sur les mêmes conception des pratiques
économiques je trouve que c'est vraiment
encombrant pour une chose qui évolue
dans le qui évolue dans le temps et qui
de toute façon et qui de toute façon a
pour finalité le servic et les volumes
donnés aux agriculteurs qui au demeurant
font leur propre déclaration voilà
comment n comprend Mons laasser j'ai
donc été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe udi UC sur les
amendements 518 rectifiés 319 rectifiés
et 324 rectifi bis je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
l'avis du Gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants
mes chers collèguue le scrutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à
voter très bien le scrutin est clos
j'invite les secrétaires à participer à
procéder au
dépouillement
mon
dernier
résultat du scrutin numéro 162 sur les
amendements 324 379 et 518 rectifiés
nombre de votants 342 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 342 pour l'adoption
167 contre 175 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
ses
amendement sur je demande un vote sur
l'amendement 200 140 rectifié TER je
signale qu'il a été en accord avec la
Commission et Monsieur deut rectifié
l'avis de la commission est favorable
l'avis du Gouvernement et sagesse qui
est
pour merci contre abstention
l'amendement est
adopté monsieur le ministre je vous
invite à présenter l'amendement 809
rectifié c'est un amendement
gouvernemental
qui vise à faire en sorte qu'on se mette
en conformité avec les modifications qui
ont été apportées dans le cadre de la
loi sur la décentralisation sur les les
les métropoles il se trouve que les
établissements publics territoriaux de
bassin sont jusqu'ici plutôt
des des institutions voilà
interdépartementales donc comment on
développe les métropoles c'est de
permettre des transitions pour ces
établissements afin d'aller vers des des
des des comment dirais-je des structures
juridiques de type syndicat mixte voilà
c'est pour ça que nous vous demandons de
voter cette amendement qui qui permet de
se mettre en conformité avec ce qui a
été voté dans le cadre de la loi de
décentralisation je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre je vais demander
l'avis de notre rapporteur favorable je
vous remercie je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement qui a eu un avis favorable
de la commission qui est
pour merci qui est contre abstention il
est adopté je suis saisie de cinq
amendements identiques faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le premier
tombe monsieur bumon nétant pas là le
235 rectifi bis est présenté par
Monsieur
bailli madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre c'est un amendement qui est
repris par plusieurs
groupes vu que on le constate je crois
que beaucoup l'ont dit dans leur
intervention hier je crois que Monsieur
le Ministre aussi peut le constater
c'est que notre élevage est en
diminution sur le pays avec toutes les
conséquences que cela en termees
économique et en terme d'emploi donc
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit tous que notre
pays a souvent des réglementations qui
vont beaucoup plus loin que les
réglementations européenses donc le but
de cet amendement c'est de dire que ne
sont pas soumises aux dispositions du
présent ti les exploitations de B de
boucherie de bovin à l'engraissement et
de vaches à l'étendes conformément à la
législation européenne donc c'est de
dire qu'en France si on
veut développer du moins reprendre un
petit peu de souffle à toute cet élevage
qui est en diminution dans ses
productions et bien de d'être moins
rigide d'autre part je crois que nous
sommes nombreux à constater je crois
qu'il y a eu de nombreuses interventions
sur ce
sujet-là pendant toutes ces années qui
montrre aussi la lourdeur des procédures
d'instruction des régimes
d'autorisation je crois que monsieur le
ministre nous l'a dit plusieurs fois que
en France souvent il fallait beaucoup
plus de temps euh pour arriver à
construire à réaliser un investissement
dans ces domaines que chez nos voisins
donc c'est pourquoi aussi on
souhaiterait que l'on simplifie quand
même ces procédures euh l'Institut de
l'Élevage nous dit qu'il faudrait 60000
places d'engraissement supplémentaires
par an pour maintenir les capacité de
production de viande en France alors
vous voyez que c'est pourquoi cet
amendement euh souhaite et demande
justement que nous ayons la
réglementation européenne mais que la
réglementation européenne sur ses
productions je n'ai pas parlé des ports
parce que là c'est un autre problème
mais je crois que sur les problèmes
quand même de V boucherie de vach
àtentees ce serait important merci je
vous remercie Monsieur B monsieur Collin
le
368tifb oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise exclure les
exploitations de veau de boucherie de
beauvin à l'engraissement et de vaches
àétente du régime des installations
classé pour la protection de
l'environnement on se comprend bien il
s'agit pas de remettre en cause
l'arsenal réglementaire tant européen
que national concernant la gestion des
flux d'azote il est en effet nécessaire
de tout mettre en œuvre pour préserver
la qualité des eaux qui s'agisse des eau
de surface ou des eaux souterraines et
bien sûr des eaux côtières je souhaite
cependant qu'un équilibre soit trouvé
entre les pratiques agricoles et les
contraintes de comp compétitivité en
l'application de la directive cadre sur
l'eau et plus spécialement de la
directive nitrate la France a fixé des
objectifs très ambitieux notamment les
exploitations de vaau de boucherie de
beauvin à l'engraissement et de vache
àétente sont intégrées au régime de
l'ICPE alors que la règlementation
européenne n'impose pas d'obligation
spécifique pour ses éleveurs il se
trouve dans l'obligation de se soumettre
à des contrôles très pointus générant
des charges de fonctionnement
conséquente et par ailleurs la filiè
française de l'engraissement qui
s'appuie sur une production de fourrage
sur l'exploitation à développer des
pratiques raisonnables en matière
d'pendage et donc afin de ne pas
fragiliser davantage C expplloitation il
convient de ne pas forcer davantage la
transition écologique dans ce secteur
voilà le sens de cet
amendement monsieur biset le 416
rectifié terre vous considérez qu'il est
défendu il est absolument défendu madame
la Présidente mais permettez-moi de
souligner par rapport aux propos que
viennent d'être tenus par nos collègues
bailli et et et écolin de de deux
choses depuis que nous avons abordé ce
projet de loi j'ai entendu des propos
qui me vont tout à fait bien j'ai
entendu le mot compétitivité j'ai
entendu le mot productivité j'ai entendu
le mot recherche innovation
simplification et bien là chich nous
avons l'opportunité de
pouvoir je dirais confirmer tout cela
nous avons un je dirais un un un péché
originel France c'est-à-dire et Monsieur
le Ministre qui a était député européen
pendant un certain nombre d'années le
sait mieux que quiconque c'est vrai que
nous ne savons pas faire comme les
Anglo-Saxons c'est-à-dire faire du
lobbying avant euh je dirais le les
l'éclosion d'une directive c'est dire au
travers des livres verts des livres
blancs nous ne savons pas travailler en
amont euh la sortie d'une directive et
une fois qu'elle est qu'elle est écrite
et bien euh la France a le péché euh je
dirais
classique de vouloir en rajouter donc là
nous sommes dans un cas de figure
excessivement clair appliquons ce que
nous demande l'Europe mais n'en faisons
pas davantage ça c'est le premier point
la deuxième chose ça a été souligné tout
à l'heure par notre collègue bayi la
France a un gros souci on le voit dans
les outils de transformation viande
blanche en Bretagne et ça risque de
gagner l'ensemble du territoire national
nous n'avons plus dans certains domaines
dans certaines filières suffisamment de
matières premières pour faire tourner
nos outils de transformation et cela il
est très important si vous voulez de on
parle de réindustrialiser la France et
bien recréons des outils de des outils
de production dans des domaines bien
particuliers qui sont beaucoup moins peu
loin qu'on ne peut l'imaginer à savoir
les Vau de boucherie les B engraissement
les vach àtente donc voilà l'objet de de
de cet
amendement on a parlé tout à l'heure de
de l'administration nous avons
l'administration la plus pertinente du
monde la plus performante du monde mais
c'est pas parce qu'elle est pertinente
c'est pas parce qu'elle est performante
qu'il faut qu'elle en fasse trop donc
voilà c'est tout
euh qui qui qui doit commander dans ce
pays gouvernement de droite ou
gouvernement de gauche passant et bien
ce n'est pas l'administration ce sont
les les les élus c'est le Parlement ce
sont les les membres du gouvernement
donc sans vouloir poser d' à l'égard de
qui que ce soit et surtout de gens
excessivement compétents et à l'écoute
n'en faisons pas
trop voilà un petit peu l'esprit de de
cet
amendement remerci monsieur bis monsieur
Lass considérez-vous que l'amendement
est défendu il est défendu je vous en
remercie monsieur le rapporteur je vais
vous demander un seul avis sur ces
amendements identiques merci madame la
Présidente nous partageons beaucoup de
choses dans ce débat et Monsieur B vient
de le dire
l'innovation la recherche l'économie la
simplification mais ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est que peut-être qui nous
oppose c'est que nous nous sommes pour
la simplification et vous vous êtes pour
la dérégulation et c'est un peu ça
peut-être la difficulté et la différence
entre nous et c'est assez fondamental
c'est assez fondamental vous
savez ça ça date pas
d'hier le les règlements ICPE pour les
beau vin viande c'est pas de
gouvernement c'est peut-être même pas du
gouvernement d'avant ça fait des années
que ça dure et je oui mais je vais vous
expliquer je vaisire pardon pas vous
expliquer je vais vous répondre mais ce
que nous ce que nous devons faire ce
n'est pas déréguler c'est simplifier et
là franchement si l'idée peut paraître
séduisante en disant bah ils en font
trop ils ont trop de choses en levant
cela mais qu'est-ce que ça peut avoir
comme conséquence derrière à vérité à
l'instanté n'est pas la vérité de demain
aujourd'hui dans le code il est bien
bien écrit que pour les régimes ICPE il
y a un C nombre il y a un C nombre de de
mesures l'autorisation l'enregistrement
la déclaration si on enlève tout cela
bah on peut faire des fermes de mille
vaches où on veut comme l'on veut sans
aucune déclaration donc c'est ça le
sujet donc aujourd'hui moi je me vois
contraint de donner un avis défavorable
à ces à ces à ces amendements on ne peut
pas totalement déglementer et déréguler
je pense que nous avons besoin
d'affirmer ici parce que nous sommes des
parlementaires le soutien à
l'administration française parce que
nous en avons besoin nous avons besoin
sur nos territoires par contre là encore
il y a deux choses différentes le
soutien à l'administration française ça
veut pas dire le soutien parfois une
bureaucratie qui pèse un peu trop non ça
ne revient pas du tout au même et c'est
peut-être une conception qui n
différencie parce que on est dans une
schizophrénie totale dans ce pays et
peut-être dans cet hémicycle on veut
moins de normes moins de régulation
moins de fonctionnaires parce que tout
tout ça coûte de l'argent par contre il
faut des policiers il faut des gendarmes
il faut des juges il faut des
enseignants il faut que sur le terrain
on faut surtout pas fermer des
sous-préfectures parce qu'il faut
qu'elles existent mais on n dit toute
l'année qu'elles ne servent à rien que
cette administration nous bloque mais
par contre on en veut encore et puis
après on se dit mais non mais il y a
trop de contraintes mais on est bien
content quand la DGCCRF ou d'autres
organismes viennent faire des contrôles
parce que sans les contrôles c'est la
c'est le libre cours à n'importe quoi
donc nous sommes un peu schizophrènes
c'est comme cela et après nous avons les
uns et les autres des postures
politiques certains se disent bah ils
sont un peu plus défenseurs de
l'administration de la fonction publique
certains un peu moins certains sont un
peu plus défenseurs d'un État fort
régulateur ass sur des fonctions
régaliennes fortes et d'autres un peu
plus libéraux ultraalibéraux ou
sociollibéraux mais peu importe on va
pas s'en excuser les uns les autres
c'est le débat politique et heureusement
qu'il y a cette confrontation mais nous
ne pouvons pas nous accepter que dans
cette loi on mette plein d'amendements
de dérégulation dont on ne sait pas
quelles conséquences ça aurait derrière
et moi j'en appelle à nous concentrer
alors c'est c'est le débat et il y a
qu'un sujet nous allons voter mais j'en
appelle à nous concentrer sur
l'essentiel on passe beaucoup de temps
sur ces sujets ils sont importants mais
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
sujets encore plus importants pour
l'avenir de l'agriculture ça ce sujet-là
ça va pas ramener de la compétitivité ça
va pas ramener du revenu ça va pas
changer nos pratiques culturales ça va
pas nous amener à regarder comment la
formation de des agriculteurs sera faite
ça va pas nous amener de l'installation
ça et il faut on a le débat on on en
discute évidemment mais moi ce que
j'aimerais qu'assz vite le plus vite
possible on arrive à parler
d'installation on arrive à parler de
foncier on arrive à parler de
renouvellement de génération on arrive à
parler de formation on arrive à parler
des des bout environnementaux sur lequel
on a trouvé des des équilibres c'est ça
les sujets importants de la loi d'avenir
la loi d'avenir de l'agriculture c'est
une loi d'avenir qui doit tracer des
pistes tracer des perspectives qui doit
ent donner des orientations et peut-être
parfois de bonnes orientations parfois
vous les considérez comme mauvaises mais
c'est le le débat démocratique c'est le
débat politique ce n'est pas ça qui est
important mais il me semble qu'ici au
Sénat peut-être plus qu'ailleurs nous
sommes tous des défenseurs et des
promoteurs de l'agriculture et surtout
nous sommes tous des défenseurs et des
promoteurs des agriculteurs c'est pour
ça que évitons me semble-t-il et ne
croyez pas que c'est je donne quelque
leçon que ce soit évitons de nous
opposer sur des sujets qui n'en valent
pas la
évitons de nous opposer sur le
fonctionnement et la façon dont
fonctionne l'administration française et
surtout évitons de nous opposer entre
ceux qui seraient du terrain et ceux qui
ne seraient pas du terrain entre ceux
qui connaissent de près ceux qui
connaissent un peu plus loin parce que
nous avons tous la même la même
conception me semble-t-il il y a des
agriculteurs il y en a qui ne sont pas
mais on peut ne pas être agriculteur et
s'intéresser à l'agriculture et dans
ceux qui sont agriculteurs on peut aussi
avoir des visions différentes et donc
essayons de partager une vision commune
une passion pour la l'agriculture celle
de son développement harmonieux sur tous
les territoires celle de ne laisser
aucun territoire au bord du chemin
essaie de faire en sorte que
l'environnement que les problèmes de
pollution et ben soit soi appréhendés et
que la la dérégulation ne soit pas la
règle vous savez souvent on se plaint au
niveau de l'Europe les uns et les autres
qu'il y a beaucoup de directives les
directives d'ailleurs en France je crois
qu'on l' dit hier mais on les transpose
peut-être monsieur le ministre un peu
trop vite et un peu trop loin ça c'est
un sujet parle devant un spécialiste
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous devrions
nous devrions vraiment réfléchir mais
souvent l'Europe parce que c'est sa
conception nous invite à déréguler et je
crois que nos concitoyens et on le verra
peut-être malheureusement le 20 quelques
mai au moment des élections européennes
je crois vraiment que nos concitoyens
non'ont pas cette cette conception là de
la dérégulation mais au contraire
veulent des règles justes et
républicaines et équitables qui est qui
encadre c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi je ne suis pas favorable à cette
proposition de d'absence d'application
du régime des des ICPE pour les beauvins
viande parce que je pense ça serait une
dérégulation ce n'est pas une contrainte
supplémentaire
y est c'est comme sur les amendements
supplément les amendements précédents
c'était pas une contrainte pour
agriculteurs supplémentaires et ils le
font la déclaration annuelle déjà donc
on ne demandait rien d'autre aux
agriculteurs c'était déjà le cas voilà
donc regardons bien les textes au fond
et disons-nous que attention la
dérégulation pourrait nous amener de
drôles de choses au détriment je pense
de l'agriculture et des agriculteurs je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre c'est le même avis défavorable
que le rapporteur pour deux arguments en
fait le premier c'est que sur cette
question des vaau boucherie bovin à
l'engressissement et vache à l'éente euh
c'est vrai que dans la directive sur les
établissements classés il y a pas de
précision pour ces types d'élevage mais
de toute façon il y a une directive sur
les études d'impact qui impose pour les
élevages intensifs une étude d'impact
donc de toute façon à l'échelle
européenne he ça c'est une directive
européenne donc de toute façon on sera
et on ne peut pas
imaginer que ce type d'élevage ou de
projet ne se fasse pas sans une étude
d'impact bon je voudrais rappeler
deuxièmement que ça serait plutôt la
définition d'ailleurs des des élevages
concernés et plutôt du domaine
réglementaire que du domaine législatif
donc de toute façon cet amendement s'il
était intégré dans la loi serait serait
pas comment dirais-je accepté ou
acceptable dans la mesure où c'est du
domaine réglementaire et puis un dernier
point moi j'ai engagé depuis que je suis
arrivé des évolutions sur les procédures
d'établissement classés avec ce qu'on a
mis en place dans le la production
porcine c'est-à-dire la procédure
d'enregistrement dans le cadre des États
généraux qui ont eu lieu il y a quelques
semaines on a prévu de continuer ce
travail pour les volailles et puis pour
à terme les les autres productions
animales puisque cette procédure
d'enregistrement simplifie c'est bien
l'objectif
les les procédures pour faire en sorte
que on est si on se situe dans des
seuils à l'échelle européenne qui sont
respecté et bien on est des procédures
qui fassent en sorte qu'on ne tout en
respectant les normes on ne perde pas le
temps qui a été quelquefois perdu par
des études longue et que sur la question
de l'impact c'est le préfet qui décide
si il y a besoin ou non de faire une
étude d'impact c'est la procédure
d'enregistrement on va
poursuivre son développement dans dans
l'ensemble des productions animales et
ça fait partie des engagements qui ont
été pris aux États généraux donc ça
c'est très important très important et
je vous le dis quand même votre
majorité il y a quelques années ENF il y
a très peu de temps c'estd quand vous
étiez majoritaire il y a 3 4 ans n'avez
pas réussi à faire bouger euh les
procédures sur les établissements
classés ce que nous avons fait donc
là-dessus ayez aussi un peu confiance on
peut toujours aller plus vite mais ce
qui a été fait sur le port on va
continuer pour mettre en place sans
remettre en cause des règles
environnementales des procédures qui
simplifient et qui raccourcissent les
durées d'instruction des projets je
crois que c'est très important de le
rappeler voilà donc je suis sur le même
avis que le rapporteur je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre je vais mettre au
voix monsieur monsieur biset je n'ai pas
vu de main se lever j'ai pensais que le
sujet était clos oh madame la Présidente
il est loin d'être classé même si nous
parlons d'établissement classés
permettez-moi quelques quelques
remarques suite aux propos tant du
ministre que que du rapporteur monsieur
le ministre vient de parler tout à
l'heure en disant ce n'est pas du
domaine de la loi c'est de domaine de
réglementaire d'acte mais en tant que
ministre vous pouvez quand même donner
quelques orientations à votre
administration et je suis persuadé
qu'elle pourra vous écouter voir vous
vous obéir c'est le souhaitable en ce
qui concerne les propos du du rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez dit
cela ne va pas amener des revenus
supplémentaires cela ne va pas amener
des installations supplémentaires je
suis désolé si vous voulez quand vous
avez un agriculteur soit sous forme
sociétaire soit directement soit avoir
un double actif sur ce ce qu'on appelle
des ateliers hors sol et bien le but et
véritablement pour avoir un complément
de revenu et quand en plus vous
assouplissez les procédures entre
guillemets réglementaire c'est un coût
supplémentaire en moins et donc moi je
peux pas entendre ce ce cette
explication vous dites dérégulations
c'est vrai qu'on ne peut être sensible
au mots dérégulation parce que si on va
trop loin dans la dérégulation c'est
c'est en fait l'anarchie et en France
nous n'aimons pas l'anarchie nous le
premier monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez dit que cette
problématique ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
ne date pas même d'hier voire
d'avant-hier on on est on est tout à
fait d'accord chaque époque a sa vérité
mais on en fait toujours un peu plus et
nous sommes en train si vous n'acceptez
pas cette amendement ces amendements
d'amener sur un plateau desps de marchés
supplémentaires à nos voisins allemands
nous manquons de 60000 places
d'engraissement dans ce pays encore une
fois et et là moi je pense que nos amis
nos nos collègues nos les sénateurs
bretons devrai m'entendre 5 sur C nous
avons entendu
dans la discussion générale notre
collègue Dominique de Lège qui a dit
très clairement dans la filière porcine
qui n'est pas concerné par ce par cet
amendement parce que c'est une
production quand même tout à fait à part
cont tenu de la nature de ces effluents
là nous ne sommes pas sur la même nature
de ces effluents il y a un quart de
siècle la France produisait 24 millions
de têtes de porc aujourd'hui entre
guillemets nous en produisons 1 million
de plus résultat vous avez pratiquement
15 15 % d'outils de transformation
d'abattage en trop dans ce pays je le
sais malheureusement trop bien puisque
je crains que si vous voulez dans
certains départements de de
basseenormandie nous ayons quelques
souci nous sommes en déficit de matières
premières pour faire travailler nos
outils de
transformation alors là encore une fois
moi je souhaiterais véritablement qu'on
dépasse si vous voulez des des problèmes
droite gauche vous nous avez beaucoup
parlé des gi2uf en disant laissz
respirer les agriculteurs laissz
s'exprimer l'innovation les projets et
cetera là nous avons un cas de figure où
on peut le faire et si nous n'y
parvenons pas permettez-moi de terminer
par je dirais un propos que j'aime assez
qui étit celui de d'Edgar fort
l'immobilisme avance monsieur rapporteur
et rien ne va pouvoir l'arrêter merci
merci Monsieur biset monsieur Bailli
ouais moi j'étais assez surpris de de la
réponse du rapporteur et et du ministre
sur ce sujetlà aujourd'hui je crois
l'avoir dit tout à l'heure on constate
tous une diminution assez importante de
de tous notre élevage ça vient d'être
dit encore nos outils de production de
transformation qui marche à faible
régime voir des licenciements et du
chômage dans les secteurs qui était très
très très agricole et je parle de la
Bretagne en particulier alors on nous
dit vous dérégulé non on dit une
réglementation européenne pourquoi aussi
ne pas que ce soit pas celle-ci qui
s'applique et de ne pas en rajouter donc
je vois pas en quoi vraiment on dérégule
on vous demande simplification aussi
mais j'aimerais peut-être je le dis
président de la commission des affaires
économiques moi j'aimerais bien qu'à ce
momentlà dans les mois qui viennent on
se penche à regarder pourquoi en
Allemagne production augmente et qu'en
France elle baisse il y a bien un
problème et on va pas continuer à se
faire sans arrêt sans arrêt dans toutes
nos productions agricole sans arrêt
prendre des part de marché par
l'Allemagne et puis à ce moment-là que
nous on on vide nos campagnes je pense
aussi que be la la la difficulté dans
dans tous les dossiers la longueur fond
et bien qu'on a des gens qui ne vont pas
plus loin et tout à l'heure ça été dit
encore par le collègue Bizet que cela
peut apporter des plus à des
agriculteurs qui amettent un atelier
complémentaire monsieur le ministre tout
à l'heure vous avez beaucoup parlé de la
méthanisation je suis pas intervenu sur
ce dossier de l'azote et cetera mais là
aussi euh si on veut remplacer euh les
les engrais euh impimporté comme vous
l'avez dit je crois aussi c'est parce
que essayons d'augmenter euh nos nos
production euh par ce que peut produire
nos élevages et la méthanisation on sait
bien demain ne pourra se faire que dans
des unités qui sont quand même assez
significatives on va pas le faire dans
les toutes petites unités donc je crois
que si on veut aussi en terme
énergétique demain pouvoir que
l'agriculture y joue pleinement son rôle
ben c'est avec une présence certaine sur
nos territoires mais une présence avec
des unités quand même qui permettent une
certaine rentabilité al c'est pourquoi
je je pensais que cet amendement allait
recevoir un consensus un petit peu de
tout le monde mais je suis vraiment déçu
que il y a des avis défavorables de
notre rapporteur et je partage si j'ai
beaucoup partagé de tout ce qu'on a fait
depuis la Commission et puis depuis hier
j'ai vraiment trouvé dans ces propos
tout à l'heure où j'ai des désaccords
avec lui et on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler je vous remercie chers
collègues dernier intervenant inscrit
sur ce cette explication de vote
monsieur
delè oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais juste dire à monsieur le
rapporteur que c'est pas un problème de
déréglementation nous ce qu'on veut
éviter c'est une
surréglementation donc ne nous dites pas
que nous refusons la réglementation nous
disons simplement nous voulons une
réglementation juste et équilibrée et on
a beaucoup parlé de la Bretagne monsieur
le ministre tout à l'heure je voudrais
en dire un
mot le fond de cette affaire c'est que
je vous crois de profonde bonne
volonté j'en suis intimement
convaincu mais à
force de nous présenter des mesures dont
vous nous dites qu'elles vont régler les
problèmes auxqueles sont confrontés les
agriculteurs et toute la filière je suis
bien obligé de constater que ce soit
votre gouvernement ou les gouvernements
précédents que ça n'a eu pour effet que
de complexifier un petit peu plus la vie
quotidienne des agriculteurs et des
entreprises qui participent du débouché
agricole et par conséquent nous sommes
au cœur du débat c'est un problème de
confiance et plus vous en rajoutez plus
on se dit mais certainement qu'il a de
bonnes idées ce ministre certainement
mais comment concrètement ça va se
traduire est-ce que ça va pas être
encore un petit peu plus de contrôle
encore un peu plus de défiance et donc
me semble que tous les amendements que
nous vous avons déposés depuis ce matin
ne vont pas dans le sens d'une
déréglementation monsieur le rapporteur
ils vont simplement dans le sens d'une
plus grande confiance entre les acteurs
de la vie économique agricole et les
administrations qui doivent les
accompagner merci Monsieur de
leè bien je crois qu'il y a une demande
de de scrutin public en
cours monsieur le ministre vous voulez
vous exprimer je vous en
prie bon je je sais pas dans les
explications de vote après le ministre
répond puis on on on on reprend le le
débat juste pour rappeler ce que vous
demandez c'est pas du du au ministr là
c'est c'est pas moins c'est pas nouvelle
réglementation c'est pas c'est moins et
c'est pas d'étude d'impact en gros sur
les Vau de boucherie les beau vins à
l'engraissement les vaches à l'étente
vous savez qu'on peut avoir par exemple
des ateliers en beauovvin en jeune
beauvin qui peuvent passer la barre des
500 des 1000 des 1000 beauovvin je je je
je vous le dis d'ailleurs dans le débat
avec les États-Unis les felotes c'est ce
qui existe et c'est ce qu'on conteste
ici en France donc prenez aussi la
mesure quand vous déposer un amendement
comme ça des conséquences est-ce que
vous seriez prêt et je prends un
sénateur ici à dessin en
Normandie aucune étude d'impact sur un
atelier de jeune bovvin à 500 bovvin à
côté de chez vous moi je vous le dis à
ce moment-là parce que vous viendriez et
vous vous seriez peut-être même puisque
si on était au gouvernement avec une
association qui consisterait à dire
c'est lamentable c'est insensé on laisse
faire n'importe quoi donc soyez aussi
vous chacun doit être
raisonnable ce que vous proposez c'est
que il y a plus de limite il y a plus
d'étude d'impact et ben je vous le dis
je je prends cet exemple là à dessin en
Normandie Basse Normandie proposition
d'installation d'un atelier de 500 à
1000 jeunes bvin
oui là aujourd'hui comme ça on verrait
après voilà donc c'est ça qui est
proposé c'est c'est pas possible c'est
pas comme oui mais par rapport à la
conception de l'agriculture et au nombre
d'agriculteur ça posera un certain
nombre de questions je vous le dis quand
même he le projet d'agricole à ce
moment-là faudra aussi s'expliquer avec
un certain nombre de de professionnels
de l'agriculture et a juste raison qui
voudront plutôt des agriculteurs que des
gros ateliers donc vous voyez bien que
votre amendement peut pas l'accepter
c'est pas un débat sur la simplification
là c'est un débat qui pose des questions
extrêmement importantes je l'ai rappelé
l'enregistrement il est en cours la
procédure près de 90 % des projets en
Bretagne vont passer de la procédure
d'autorisation à la procédure
d'enregistrement dixite le préfet des
côtes d'armort c'est pas rien ça va
réduire les durées donc on est bien dans
la simplification sans être pour autant
dans l'absence ça a été dit tout à
l'heure de réglementation parce que de
toute façon il y a besoin aussi de
réglementation donc on on peut pas se
faire de faux débats ou de faux procès
là-dessus et je vous le dis là sur tel
que c'est mis là aujourd'hui pensez et
réfléchissez un instant aux conséquences
que ça pourrait avoir des Grands
Ateliers de fil lotte en France se ferit
sans étude d'impact je crois pas que
vous-même vous en soyez vous vous
l'accepteriez donc rest dans l'objectif
simplifier réduire les durées respecter
les règles environnementales c'est ça
l'objectif merci monsieur le ministre
après les explications monsieur le
ministre est-ce que la demande de
scrutin public est maintenue elle est
maintenue très bien
donc sur les amendements sur tous les
amendements identiques 235 368 416 552
rectifié bis je vous rappelle que l'avis
de la commission est défavorable la viis
du Gouvernement est défavorable il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques
instants merci le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à
voter très bien le scrutin est donc clos
j'invite les secrétaires à procéder au
dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 163 sur les
amendements 235 368 46 et 552 rectifiés
nombre de votant 344 nombre de suffrage
é 344 pour l'adoption 169 contre 175 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance pour 5 minutes la séance est
suspendue mes chers collègues la séance
est reprise je suis saisie de C
amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune j'appelle monsieur
denu s'il est revenu non non donc ah
Monsieur denu est-ce que vous souhaitez
présenter le 238 rectifiéire vous
considérez qu'il est défendu ah il est
retiré très bien je vous
remercie le 294 rectifié bis monsieur
César le
présente la présidente en effet le 294
est un amendement très important et nous
proposons de supprimer les alignat de 7
à 12 car en l'état actuel du droit le
champ d'application du B avait close
avmentale par est suffisant pour
répondre aux enjeux de la protection et
de la biodiversité en particulier dans
les zones sensibles voilà voilà pourquoi
nous avons déposé cette amendementci
monsieur César le 353 rectifié monsieur
Collin je considère qu'il est défendu
puisque c'est le
même le 60 rectifié monsieur revet
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 41 27 du codre et de la pêche
maritime prévoi la possibilité d'insérer
des clauses environnementales dans les B
de cas de figure sont aujourd'hui
possibles les parcelles sont détenus par
un bailleur personne morale de droit
public une association agréée de
protection de l'environnement une
personne morale agréée les parcelles
sont détenues par un bailleur autre que
mentionné précédemment c'est-à-dire
bailleur
privé disposition réglementaire prévoi
une liste de clauses environnementales
pouvant être insérées dans le bail ainsi
l'article l41 31 du codre rur de la
pêche maritime prévoit que le bail
peut-être résilié si le preneur ne
respecte pas les clauses insérées dans
le bail la possibilité d'insérer des
clauses environnementales dans les B
n'est pas neutre de conséquence
puisqu'elle permet la résation du bail
en cas de défaut du preneur un éventuel
élargissement de cette disposition
entraînerait des conséquences mal
maîtrisées cette disposition doit donc
être encadré par ailleurs l'un des
piliers fondamentaux du statut du
fermage sur la liberté
d'exploitation le preneur a le choix de
conduire ses pratiques sans
l'intervention de son bailleur aussi
lorsque les parcelles sont situées dans
une zone les clauses doivent répondre au
documents de gestion officiel du bien
loué or l'égalité de traitement entre
citoyens devant la loi les règlements
constituent un principe général du droit
que les autorités administratives
doivent respecter dans législation et
réglementation qu'ell mettent en œuvre
il est donc indispensable que les
clauses environnementales ne puissent
être inséré dans les beau quel quel que
soit le bailleur qu'uniquement dans le
cas où la parcelle serait situé dans un
zonage environnemental elles devront
être en conformité avec le document de
gestion du biené par ailleurs monsieur
le ministre je suis intervenu juste
avant l'article
1 hier pour vous demander c était plutôt
lié à la pêche mais c'est tout
l'ensemble du littoral sous les yeux il
y a quelques années des projets de
classement depuis d'unquerque jusqu'à
monts-michel pour ne parler que du
Nord-Ouest la vallée de Scine et en
différents endroits de de vallée de
Seine à travers des zones tout le
littoral zone Natura 2000 littoral ou
autres or il y a des incidences pardà le
schéma que je vous ai demandé et
j'aimerais bien avoir une réponse savoir
si on le fait et je vous ai pas dit
parce que j'ai pas voulu être long hier
que s'agissant par exemple deaaculture
on a diminué de moitié en 10ant la
production qu'aujourd'hui la France
importe 85 % des besoins de ses besoins
en poisson et crustacés c'est quand même
dramatique pour le un pays qui dispose
de 2e zone maritime du monde je mais je
vous ai écrit ENF je sais plus si c'est
à vous ou ou ou avant il y a déjà
plusieurs mois parce que j'ai été
interrogé par la vallée de Scine tout le
long du littoral par les propriétaires
et exploitants qui voulit savoir quelles
étaient les
conséquences d'un
classement de de ces zones les
conséquences sur la valeur vénale des
terrains et les conséquences parce que
dè lors qu'il y a des normes très
strictes pour l'exploitation fatalement
ça a une une incidence sur le le
résultat je n'ai pas eu de réponse à ce
jour alors je pourrais vous envoyer le
double de ce courrier monsieur le
ministre pour que vous puissiez me
l'envoyer parce que c'est pas c'est pas
innocent c'est ça concerne l'ensemble du
littoral et ce qui est vrai pour le la
partie nord-ouest c'est sûrement vrai
ailleurs donc monsieur le
ministre c'est pour ça que j'ai déposé
cet amendement et que je souhaite que
vous puissiez le prendre en compte et
s'il vous plaît comme vous avez dépassé
votre temps de parole je vous demande de
de présenter le 197 rectifié de manière
plus
succinte
le suivant oui parce que je suis
cignataire écoute les défendus alors il
est défendu
m mieux je vous le sugérer quand même
bien je vais demander à notre à notre
rapporteur son avis sur ses
amendements merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le
Ministre on évoquit tout à l'heure les
taquet les gros sujets et celui-ci en
est le bail environnemental tel qu'il
avait
été issu de l'Assemblée nationale ne
nous convenait pas et ne me convenait
pas je considérais que c'était un frein
à la possibilité pour les agriculteurs
et notamment pour les jeunes qui
s'installe de de de travailler parce qu'
s liimitait trop de contraintte et c'est
pour ça j'ai souhaité que nous
réécrivions la partie sur le bail
environnemental et je pensais que nous
avions on trouvé en commission un
compromis sur lequel j'avais compris
d'ailleurs que nous étions tous d'accord
ce compromis était assez clair on ne
rajoute pas des contraintes sur les
beaux
environnementaux mais en même temps on
se dit pas de retour sur les pratiques
vertueuses faut éviter les retours mais
on n rajoutait pas plus et là vous
présentez des amendement de suppression
et moi je peux pas être d'accord avec
les amendements de suppression parce que
supprimer ce que nous avons on fait
unanimement en en commission revient
mais ça c'est l'avis de du Parlement et
de l'hémicycle les sénateurs sont
souverains dans l'hémicycle évidemment
mais remet totalement en cause le
travail que nous avons fait sur lequel
nous avons passé plusieurs heures de
d'audition et sur lequel nous avons bien
travaillé je voudrais simplement vous
rappeler par ce que tout à l'heure mon
ami Gérard Baili me disait mais on n'est
pas d'accord je suis déçu par ce que
disait le le le rapporteur je peux le
comprendre mais on n pas la même vision
sur tous les sujets c'est bien normal
mais heureusement mais il me semblait
mais oui oui absolument mais il me
semblait que sur six points importants
de la loi que nous avions considéré tous
comme des points importants nous
l'avions amélioré et nous avions trouvé
le point d'équilibre et le point de
compromis c'est sur la triple
performance dans les
G2 économique sociale et
environnementale et faire rentrer la
partie sociale c'était très important
c'était un compromis sur la clause
miroir pour les coopératives nous en
parlerons le texte nous convenait pas
nous avons trouvé un compromis et un
compromis d'ailleurs sur ce point qui a
été validé par le par le gouvernement en
disant ne rajoutant pas des contraintes
au aux coopératives et ne faisons pas en
sorte que dans toutes les assemblées
générales doivent tout mettre les
conseils d'administration sont là pour
ça nous avons trouvé un compromis grâce
notamment d'ailleurs à Monsieur lasser
et à Monsieur du bois sur la
compensation agricole et nous avons
avancé nous allons avancer encore et si
j'ai bien compris parce que je sais que
vous avez eu les responsables agricoles
que finalement les responsables
agricoles sont d'accord sur l'écriture
du Sénat sur la compensation sur la
compensation agricole sur la question du
loup nous en parlerons nous avons je
crois trouvé un compromis et j'espère
que tout à l'heure demain ou je sais pas
quand unanimement nous affirmons des
choses très claires parce qu'il y a des
moments où l'intérêt général prime sur
tout le sur tout le reste nous avons
nous avions des interrogations sur le
transfert à l'aness des AMM et nous
avons trouvé un compromis pour dire il
faut absolument que le maintien du droit
de regard du ministre soit là et que le
ministre puisse dire des choses et là
madame Blandin a même rajouté un
amendement pour dire là encore pas de
retour en arrière sur tous ces points
qui sont à mon sens fondamentaux il y en
a beaucoup d'autres mais sur tous ces
points fondamentaux la commission des
Affaires économiques sous la houlette de
de daniel Raoul a trouveré un compromis
et moi ce que je voudrais vous dire ce
matin je vous engage je nous
engage sur ces sujetsl où après des
heures d'auditions des heures de
discussion en commission où j'avais
compris que nous avions un compromis je
nous engage à voter sur ces compromis
sur le reste tous les débats on a vu
tout à l'heure sur l'azot et tous les
débats sont légitimes ils sont
d'ailleurs tous légitimes mais lorsque
nous avons trouvé un compromis je crois
qu'il faut le tenir et je pensais que
sur le bail environnemental nous avions
trouvé un compromis que ce compromis il
était assez clair c'est de dire ne ne
baissons pas ne réduisons pas les choses
mais ne mettons pas de contraintes
supplémentaire notamment sur un sujet
que j'avais expertisé moi dans mon
département ce sujet il était assez
simple un jeune qui s'installe qui va
prendre des parcelles par-ci par là un
hectare par-ci 2 hectares par là avec
des propriétaires différents mais si à
ce jeune on lui dit ben là tu vas faire
du bio là tu vas faire ceci là tu vas
faire cela ça ne marche pas et ça c'est
des contraintes c'est des normes et
c'est des c'est des choses
insupportablees et on ne peut pas
l'accepter c'est pour ça que j'espère
qu'en 2è lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale aura la sagesse de
ne pas réécrire en 2è lecture le texte
de la première lecture parce que il
ratatine tous les efforts qui peuvent
être fait de bonnes pratiques agricoles
et notamment chez les jeunes que pas sur
les pas pas sur les jeunes c'est pour ça
que le compromis c'était on maintient
les cas existants les cas existants on n
demande pas plus mais pas moins et on
permet en outre à tout propriétaire de
proposer un bail environnemental parce
que parce que quand même quand là on est
tous d'accord pour les pratiques
environnemental et c'est normal qu'un
propriétaire puisse mettre un bail
environnemental mais on ne rajoute pas
des contraintes supplémentaires le débat
précédent sur la dérégulations sur les
normes sur la simplification c'est
exactement ça ne rajoutons pas des
contraintes aux agriculteur qui
s'installent ou à ceux qui achètent des
des des des parcelles et notamment les
seules clauses admissibles seraient des
clauses garantissant le maintien des
bonnes pratiques et pas l'imposition de
normes supplémentaires c'est inscrit
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
que ce garde-fou que l'on a mis en
commission pendant des heures il est
suffisant et votre amendement monsieur
César les autres amendements il le le
celui qui s'en rapproche le plus deessi
de la commission c'est d'ailleurs celui
de Monsieur de Monsieur de Monsieur
revet mais le gardefou qu'on a vu non
mais c'est la réalité mais le gardefou
qu'on a mis en
commission paraî suffisant et votre
amendement il supprime purement et
simplement l'extension du bail
environnemental donc moi je je suis
désolé je je vous demanderai je sais pas
si vous serez d'accord de retirer cet
amendement de garder la position de
compromis qui est une position qui à mon
sens a été acceptée par la profession
agricole par ceux dans la profession
agricole toute tendance confondue qui
pense que il faut quand même mettre un
certain nombre de de barrières parce
qu'on peut pas faire n'importe quoi mais
qu'on ne revient pas en arrière qu'on en
demande pas toujours plus c'est pour ça
que je j'aimerais je souhaiterais que
vous retiriez votre amendement vous
l'avez défendu vous avez donné vos
positions au profit du compromis
politique et professionnel que nous
avons obtenu en commission on maintient
le bail environnemental on met les
gardes-fous pas de retour en arrière
mais pas de contraintes supplémentaires
parce que les contraintes parfois et ben
on commence à en avoir un peu marre
voilà donc évidemment avis de madame la
Présidente avis de de de retrait où je
me verrai dans l'obligation de de donner
un avis défavorable parce que c'est un
retour sur le compromis et à mon avis
sur quelque chose qui peut fonctionner
et bien fonctionner monsieur le
rapporteur j'attends de vous des avis
sur le 60 rectifié et le 197 rectifiés
ce sont des avis de retrait
ou des avis défavorables celui qu'on
pourrait intégrer c'est en partie celui
de Monsieur rev mais il est alors on
pourrait rajouter un amendement le
rectifier de rédactionnel mais enfin il
est dans le texte de la commission me
semble-t-il et donc j'aimerais qu'on
puisse limiter au au texte de la
commission très bien donc retrait ou
avis défvorable pour l'ensemble des
amendements monsieur le ministre l'avis
du Gouvernement sur ces amendements sur
les amendements c'est le même avis que
le rapporteur je voulais juste rajouter
une chose sur monsieur le sénateur rev
sur la question que vous avez évoqué
déjà hier oui je prendrai l'initiative
de rencontrer le ministère de l'Écologie
et sgolen royale avec le secrétaire
d'État maintenant à l'économie maritime
pour qu'on puisse traiter la question
littorale et surtout je vous le dis la
grande question posée par l'aquaculture
ça c'est un vrai sujet on a là à
reprendre ce sujet et à remettre en
route une production et une filière tout
à fait d'accord avec vous donc je vous
ferai à vous de manière spécifique
compte rendu des rencontres que j'auris
et des objectifs qu'on se sera fixés en
commun je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre très bien j'ai plusieurs
demandes d'explication de vote monsieur
César oui merci madame la Présidente le
le rapporteur comme le ministre vient de
rappeler que il y avait une clause et un
engagement de tous de de trouver un
accord unan
au sein de la commission des affaires
économiques je vis demanderis au
rapporteur si l'alinéa 10 qui dit ceci
petit à pour garantir sur là ou les
parcelles mises à bail le maintien de
ces pratiques ou infrastructures est-ce
que c'est bien ça que nous avons voté en
commission c'était ça ma question et si
c'est ça si si le rapporteur le confirme
officiellement disant qu'il maintient
donc l'alinéa 10 à ce moment là nous
retirerons notre amendement monsieur le
rapporteur oui monsieur César je vous
remercie de votre intervention ce que
nous avons mis c'est ce que vous venez
de dire pour garantir sur là où les
parcelles et cetera le maintien des
pratiques c'est-à-dire que on on peut on
peut changer si on veut mais voilà sur
la base du volontar on n'impose pas du
plus par contre on ne revient pas en
arrière sur ce qui était fait donc on
est totalement revenu sur ce qui avait
été fait à l'assemblée qui complexifiait
et si ça vous a convaincu je vous
remercie vraiment monsieur César de de
votre position non nous avons bien non
nous avons bien travaillé tous ensemble
dans l'intérêt des agriculteurs je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur y a-t-il
encore des demandes de parole malgré cet
accord monsieur Deneu
alors moi moi je voudrais me rallier à
l'AVE de monsieur le rapporteur en lui
disant peut-être ne l'avit-il pas
remarqué que j'avais déjà rallé l'avis
de la commission en enlevant
l'amendement que nous avions déposé et
pour la compréhension des débats il faut
que vous compreniez que ces gens qui
comme moi parfois nous regrettons ne
sont plus à la Commission des affaires
chcho ne connaissant pas les débats
internes de cette commission nous avions
pris la préaution de déposer mais ayant
appris qu'il y avait un compromis moi je
m m été rallé tout de suite tout de
suite alors n'insistons pas sur ce
compromis j'aurais pu vous rappeler ma
situation personnelle moi j'ai été
fermier sur 106 hectares avec 23
propriétaires et 82 parcelles catastral
voyez ce que peut donner
l'application merci Monsieur denneu
monsieur
Dubois et Madame présidente monsieur le
ministre euh nous avons ça a été dit par
monsieur le rapporteur nous avons
beaucoup travaillé en commission euh un
accord a été trouvé et le groupe uduic
avait retiré son amendement compte tenu
de des décisions qui avait été prise et
du compromis qui nous paraît tout à fait
équilibré on ne tire pas un trait sur le
passé mais on en rajoute pas pour
l'avenir merci chers collègues est-ce
que je peux considérer que l'ensemble
des amendements ont été retirés monsieur
revet
oui merci madame la Présidente je suis
comme Monsieur de Neu il se trouve que
la commission des affaires économiques a
été divisée en deux et que nous ne
participons pas pour un certain nombre
d'entre nous aux travaux c'est d'une
certaine façon dommage même si on
travaille bien à la commission merci de
me dire que que l'on vous manque mais
mais mais si vous voulez même si nous
faisons du très bon travail dans la
commission de de l'environnement il
n'empêche que nous avons pas participé à
cette réflexion mais ceci
étant mes collègues qui participent et
je leur fais totalement
confiance
ayant pris en compte les évolutions qui
ont été travaill TR dans la Commission
et les résultats auquel on est parvenu
et et monsieur le rapporteur ayant
indiqué que le seul qui pourrait
peut-être être adopté c'est celui que
j'ai déposé puisqu'il est très proche du
travail de la commission je vais retirer
celui-ci et le suivant et et bien
entendu s'il y avait quelque chose on
verrait plus tard mais pour l'instant
ils vont être retirés merci je vous
remercie monsieur revet toute la série
donc des amendements a été retiré je
suis saisie de six amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur César vous présentez le 313
rectifié vous êtes le premier signataire
de ce cet
amendement
merci de supprimer les annéesa donc 13
et 14 par rapport donc aux dispositions
qui sont prises en particulier au niveau
des B voilà j'ai résumé parfaitement
enfin je sais pas si c'est parfait mais
au moins je l'ai résumé merci Monsieur
César le 534 rectifié monsieur Dubois
c'est un amendement
identique il vient d'être défendu madame
la Présidente de façon explicite
efficace rapide merci chers
collègu monsieur le C monsieur le C oui
c'est le même amendement donc ce
dispositif risque de fragiliser le
statut du fermage en permettant
d'exercer des pressions sur le fermier
qui n'est pas en position de force c'est
pourquoi nous vous demandons de
supprimer ces alinéas et de revenir à
c'està-dire la mise à disposition au
profit d'une société objet
principalement agricole je vous remercie
Monsieur Le Cam le 754 n'est pas défendu
il tombe monsieur l'abbé vous présentez
le 126
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues si on a
l'impression d'avancer quelque peu
difficilement lorsque l'on entend les
débats du côté de de la droite la
transition est une absolue nécessité et
attendue par une grande partie du monde
agricole et aussi par la société civile
et par nos nos concitoyens donc cet
amendement vise à accompagner un
mouvement qui est déjà en cours donc une
un propriétaire bailleur peut lorsqu'il
a contacté un bail rural avec une
personne morale du type Gaek ou sccea se
retrouver lié à des personnes qu'il n'a
pas choisi initialement par le jeu des
fluctuation possible dans la composition
de la structure preneur du bail pour se
prémunir de cette situation le bailleur
a la possibilité de signer le bail non
plus avec la structure morale mais
directement avec les associés qui
mettent alors le bail à disposition de
la structure juridique qu'ils ont choisi
pour l'exploitation du bien mais le code
rural ne désigne comme structure pouvant
bénéficier d'une mise à disposition que
des sociétés à objet principalement
agricoes dont le capital doit être
majoritairement détenu par des personne
physique or si les formes sociétaires se
développent de façon importante dans le
monde agricole il existe aussi un
développement d'autres formes
d'organisation entre personnes
partageant un projet agricole notamment
sous forme d'association 1901 à l'image
des AMAP ou encore les pépinières
d'activités agricoes visant à permettre
à des porteurs de projets de se tester
avant de se lancer dans leur activité
agricole en production
biologique
aujourd'hui la mise à disposition d'un
bail rural à une association n'étant pas
possible elles ne peuvent être
représenté que par le biais indirect
d'un de leurs membres directement
preneur du bail au détriment de leur
volonté de partage collectif des
responsabilité liée à la production et à
l'entretien du bien monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente je serais vraiment
vraiment très déçu de ne pas avoir un
avis favorable sur cette proposition
progressiste et qui suit la volonté de
la société je vous remercie monsieur
l'abbé la parole est à monsieur Dubois
pour défendre le 519
rectifié la présidente monsieur le
ministre excusez-moi ça ça ça a un lien
très direct avec les amendements que
nous venons de de déposé précédemment et
et c'est sur la définition de la société
on parle de société à vocation
principalement agricole et nous nous
souhaitons Sanger cette phrase par les
mots à objet agricole à objet agricole
c'est dire uniquement gérer des sociétés
dont l'objet et bien de
transformer et de cultiver la terre donc
des sociétés agricoles je vous remercie
chers collègues je vais donc demander à
notre rapporteur son avis sur ces
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente je vais vous
faire une réponse de
progressiste pour faire plaisir à
Monsieur l'abbé parce qu'il dis faut
être
progressiste comment non non non faut
pas s'en méfier parce que je vais donner
un avis favorable aux amendements de
Monsieur César de monsieur Dubois de
Monsieur Le Cam je vais donner un avis
défavorable à celui de Monsieur l'abbé
et le vôtre monsieur monsieur Dubois le
dernier le 519 malheureusement il tombe
mais ce que vous avez
il tombe forcément si on VO celui de
Monsieur César mais ce que vous avez
ajouté à objet agricole moi m'intéresse
beaucoup et peut-être que dans la
deuxème lecture faudrait voir comment on
pourrait l'intégrer dans le comment on
pourrait l'intégrer dans le dans le dans
le
texte je crois que un bail rural c'est
personnel on passe un bail avec
quelqu'un avec un un agriculteur et
transférer un bail ça existe on pourrait
com prendre mais à une personne qui
n'est pas forcément
agriculteur toujours pareil par rapport
à ce qui caractérise la les lignes
forces de cette loi revient peut-être à
amoindrir la force de l'agriculture au
profit d'autres c'est pas un procès
d'intention c'est tout simplement de se
dire que il faut que on ne peut pas
accepter un portage de de bail parce que
à l'arrivée si on laissait cela ça
pourrait
présenter des risques de détournement du
statut du fermage en fait c'est ça voilà
et c'est suffisant c'est suffisamment
fragile le statut du fermage que je vous
propose pas monsieur l'abbé j'en suis
désolé de de vous soutenir sur le sujet
par contre je donne des avis favorable
aux autres celui de 519 tombe on
regardera la suite et si nous faisons
cela je pense que nous assurons nous
assurons la
transmission de de terre nous assurons
la la qualité des des beaux ruraux et
nous évitons nous évitons d'éventuelles
dérives merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du
Gouvernement je vous
remercie très bien bien il n a pas de
demande d'explication de vote monsieur
l'abbé le véritable progrès est toujours
victime d'inquiétudes qui sont qui son
qui ne sont pas forcément fondé et là
c'est véritablement le cas
la société civile la l'agriculture
certes c'est l'affaire des agriculteurs
et heureusement mais l'agriculture n'est
plus que l'affaire des agriculteurs des
agriculteurs est l'affaire de l'ensemble
de la société que l'on représente
ici merci monsieur l'abbé je vais
monsieur le
rapporteur je j'ai fait tout à l'heure
l'explication plus large je veux
répondre très précisément et très de
façon très précise et technique
excusez-moi en lisant l'argumentaire
à Monsieur l'abbé pour bien dire que il
y a pas d'opposition on n'est pas là
pour se confronter sur ces sujets mais
ce que vous proposez c'est que le
bailleur puisse non seulement mettre le
baille rural dont il dispose à
disposition d'une société objet agricole
monsieur Dubois monsieur César nous en
sommes d'accord dont il est membre mais
également à toute association loi 1901
dont il serait membre et je crois que
c'est là où il y a où il y a un problème
je mets pas du tout en cause les
associations loi 1911 c'est pas le sujet
mais c'est un détournement du peut
s'apparenter un détournement du statut
du fermage d'abord cette mise à
disposition ne ne nécessiterait pas
l'accord du propriétaire bailleur donc
ça pose quand même un problème du statut
de la de de la propriété et puis un tel
montage paraît difficilement acceptable
le Baas m à disposition d'une
exploitation en effet le bail est mis à
disposition d'une exploitation agricole
ça c'est la la règle cette faculté de
mise à disposition vise à laisser
l'agriculteur libre liberté de
l'agriculteur de de la forme juridique
de l'exploitation or les associations
loi 1901 ne peuvent pas constituer le
support juridique d'une exploitation
agricole et donc dans une loi d'avenir
sur l'agriculture on est bien là pour
conforter les exploitations agricoles
c'est là où nous avons une divergence je
comprends la philosophie de ce que vous
dites enfin c'est pas tout à fait
l'objet de de la loi et donc il y aurait
une sorte de perte de contrôle du
bailleur sur son bien ce qui pose
quandme problème qui passerait dans dans
d'autres main sans qu'il en ait
connaissance ou qu'il puisse s'y opposer
et donc ça ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas possible que il y ait un bail
qui soit donné et puis après ça change
de main le propriétaire n'a absolument
pas son mot à dire et il n'a rien à dire
sur ce que deviendrait l'objet du bail
c'està-dire ce que deviendrait les
terres donc c'est vraiment une atteinte
au statut du fermage qui me paraît
excessif je le dis sans être excessif
moi-même c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur l'abbé je pense que je
comprends l'intention qui vous anime
dans cette dans cet amendement mais je
pense ça peut aller peut-être ça
peut-être mais ça peut aller à l'envers
de ce pourquoi nous travaillons depuis
des jours et si j'ai bien compris nous
allons continuer au rythme où nous
allons pendant des jours c'est de
conforter l'agriculture le statut de
l'agriculteur et les exploitations
agricoles voilà merci monsieur le
rapporteur je vais donc mettre au voix
l'amendement 313 rectifié le 534
rectifiés et le
599 qui sont identiques ils ont reçu un
avis favorable du rapporteur et un avis
de sagesse du gouvernement qui est
pour merci qui est contre abstention ils
sont
adoptés monsieur je suis désolé monsieur
l'abé le votre tombe et celui monsieur
Dubois
également monsieur Dubois votre
amendement est tombé là i il est tombé
madame la Présidente mais j'ai noté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les les propos tenus
par monsieur le rapporteur pour la
seconde lecture très bien merci bien
j'ai un à l'article 4 toujours un
amendement 177 il est présenté par
Madame Blandin madame la Présidente vous
avez la parole merci chers collègues
c'est le dernier sur le bien-être
animal cet amendement porte sur le cadre
qui s'offre aux mutation de
l'agriculture et de la transformation
des aliments la transformation des
produits est en adaptation permanente
sous la pression de goût ou de besoins
nouveaux besoins souvent créés par la
publicité la grande distribution ainsi
que sous la pression des marchés car les
matière alimentair restent hélas des
marchandises soumises à spéculation la
science ance ouvre des possibilités sans
cesse renouvelé de modifier alimentation
reproduction forme productivité des
animaux d'élevage mais il doit y avoir
des limites éthiques ce n'est pas parce
qu'on sait le faire que l'on doit le
faire même si cela rapporte plus
d'argent à certains qui au passage sont
rarement les éleveurs eux-mêmes le texte
qui nous est proposé est équilibré
il évoque la qualité des produits ce
n'est pas parce que l'on sait produire
du bœuf aux hormones que l'on vend en
produire au risque de perturber le
métabolisme des consommateurs et celui
des enfants aménagement du territoire ce
n'est pas parce qu'il serait plus simple
de cultiver et élever en pleain qu'on va
abandonner les paysans des montagnes
maintien de l'emploi en milieu rural ce
n'est pas parce que des professeurs
Nimbus veulent appliquer les recette du
BTP ou de la science-fiction aux étables
qu'on va faire des usines à mil vaches
et transformer nos campagnes en parc
d'attraction le cadre proposé est donc
vertueux mais il y a un oubli le respect
du bien-être animal faute de cette
mention nous n'aurions aucun outil pour
décourager les pratiques de mutilation
ou
d'immobilisation favorable à la
production mais génératrice aujourd'hui
de souffrance et demain de misise normes
douloureuses et coûteuses voire de
faillite quand tomberont les règle de
Bruxelles de plus un cadre vertueux en
matière de bien-être animal est une
protection pour nos éleveurs car c'est
bien
l'agroalimentaire qui tire les prix vers
le bas importe n'importe quoi se moque
des conditions d'élevage au Brésil ou à
Taïwan et ruine les producteurs de nos
régions vous avez tous vu l'émission de
télévision qui nous montrait les
ateliers farmort d'une célèbre
coopérative et les poulets lowcost
importés du Brésil et de Taïwan je vous
remercie madame la Présidente je vais
demander l'avis de notre rapporteur sur
cette question le 177 merci Madame La la
la présidente madame
Blandin le bien-être animal a été
rajouté dans la loi dans les dans les
objectifs de la politique agricole
générale c'est la première fois qu'il a
été fait et sur ce sujet tout le monde
était d'accord par contre je ne peux pas
être d'accord d'en faire un objet
spécifique parce que alors après on s'en
sortira pas et de le mettre dans le Code
Rural ce n'est pas possible donc je
pense que on peut dire qui peut le plus
peut le moins ou qui peut le moins peut
le plus mais c'est inscrit dans le
premier article dans le cadre de la
politique générale agricole et je ne
crois pas je ne pense pas qu'il faille
en faire
un objectif spécifique je comprends que
vous présentiez votre votre amendement
mais je vous demanderai de bien vouloir
le retirer auquel cas je me verrai
contrain de sinon je me verrai contrain
de donner un avis défavorable oui pour
la la mise l'écriture dans la politique
générale et pour en faire une
orientation non pour le mettre de façon
à faire un objectif spécifique de la
politique agricole parce que ce n'est
pas un objectif spécifique de la
politique agricole on pourrait prendre
plein d'autres plein d'autres secteurs
de la société où on pourrait en parler
donc je pense qu'il limitonsnous et
c'est la première fois que ça y est à
l'inscrire dans la boutique générale et
ça sera une grande avancée déjà que nous
aurons sur le sur ce sujet je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
du Gouvernement sagesse même avis que le
rapporteur sagesse ou même avis que le
sagesse sage sagesse d'accord merci très
bien Madame Blandin madame la Présidente
vous souhaitez répondre une explication
de vote ben écoutez je vais le retirer
pour faire gagner du temps je ne suis
pas assurée d'avoir une majorité mais
monsieur Guillaume a laissé passer la
dernière occasion de soigner son karma
vis-à-vis des espèces
animales merci madame la Présidente pour
ce retrait voilà pour l'examen de cet
article 4 qui portait sur l'utilisation
de fertilisants azotés à l'origine de la
création des fameuses algues vertes je
vous rappelle que ce projet de loi sur
l'agriculture a finalement été adopté
par le Sénat le 15 avril dernier vous
pouvez toujours revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site sur
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires